right we're here at London Film and
comic-con been in so many movies I'm
sure you've got lots of highlights your
career which ones stand out for you in
particular uh you know ever every single
movie I've had a different experience on
but always a great experience and I get
to sort of tap into different fantasies
as a kid for different roles like with
x-men and and the GI Joe was my most
recent playing Snake Eyes is I wanted to
be a ninja as a kid you know and that
was one of the other reasons why I went
to martial arts apart from Star Wars and
been brought up on Star Wars I just I
felt a blast doing every single thing I
do you mentioned of course Star Wars
there we've gotta ask you what was it
like playing Darth Maul at the time it
was more of a thanks and a tribute to my
martial art teachers and my parents
because as a kid as a fortune or a kid I
made the choice that I want to get into
film and I want to be able to do stunts
and acting and do the action and I just
knew I wanted to be part of it in some
way and so I didn't know how I was going
to do I just knew by training in martial
arts I was going to get there somehow so
when I actually landed the parts Darth
Maul I just finished competing for Great
Britain in wushu and it was like a dream
come true to sort actually to get to use
my martial arts training because risa
trained for ten hours a day was the pea
wrong way to competitions player on
track suits so to get paid to do
something that I love was a big big it
was a big compliment
and a big lie here I'm only that I'd see
a toad you and then now doing
conventions and doing appearances that's
when the feeling of what does it feel
like to be Dartmoor we know through the
fans you have to hear everything that
fans tell me and and then to be
appreciated in that way and then to it
for my nieces and nephews to be at
school in and for them to be like like
not all of their friends believe that
their big encore is Darth Maul so it's
nice is it goes through that when I see
them I'm really proud and I'm glad that
it's all about the kids as well you know
we're all big kids and that's why we're
here but to see through other kids and
to be part of that like to be their
uncle and enter for them to get
recognition like theirs
it's awesome you must be the coolest
uncle they must be so pleased you're
there and cool I'll find that tomorrow
because they're gonna come down and I'm
gonna I'm gonna try and introduce them
to everyone so I've pre-warned a lot of
the Star Wars guys that I know so if you
don't mind I'm gonna have a big team of
people coming down I'm gonna I'm not an
ask for anything I just want him to meet
you you know thinking back it wasn't
like making your first movie my first
film was Mortal Kombat annihilation and
what stood out to me was I remember the
time I didn't want to act I remember
looking at it and I looks boring I want
to do action but it was also it wasn't
like the and then I realized what I was
doing when I was doubling for someone
else I don't want to be a stuntman I
realize I don't wanna be someone I want
to do the whole thing and so I was lucky
enough to land ours more where I got to
do everything and it was I was just very
interested in how things operated how
why do they say certain things where you
do for terminology for a film or can
and I was just learning every day it was
like a new cross was the x-men
experience like and GI Joe as well
compared to those movie because of my
experience on Mortal Kombat and Star
Wars I got to do a lot of stunts so it
made it easier for x-men and for x-men
of course I wanted to be like Wolverine
or gambit and not be green and not be
hunched and but I'm actually glad I
played the character you know it was
just because I do know the comics and
I'm grateful for it and I got to spend 6
to 7 months in Toronto so I got to have
it in a new a new living experience
somewhere else I got something Patrick
Stewart Hugh Jackman I got to work with
one of my teenage crisis with was Halle
Berry so I got to work with her and I
remember when I was 15 been a Huggle
she's so beautiful and things like that
you know that it's a it was all it like
couldn't believe it's happening I'm
working with these fantastic people well
finally of course you've got more Star
Wars movies coming 7 8 & 9 JJ Abrams is
on board what do you think about that
what would you like to see happen in the
Star Wars movies and if you could come
back as anything what would you like to
be I think it's great that JJ's doing it
I think he I've known for many years
he's a big star Wars fan it's what he's
done with Star Trek is phenomenal and I
think he's the great he's a right man
for the job and and I'm ecstatic that
Star Wars is coming back because when I
was when I was a kid I used to go why
did they film four five and six and when
are they gonna do six seven and eight
I'm when I gonna do one two three and
it's no not yeah and so now they're
actually doing it and with it with the
Clone Wars and you know I thought I've
said that I will play anything to do
with Star Wars but really did down I'd
love to come back as Darth Maul that's
what I want to do I would do that I
would go crazy governmental getting
locked myself in the cabin Oh No
do the whole method and two or three
months and you know spearfishing and
stuff and just to play the character
again we look forward to that thank you
so much for speaking to us great to the
pleasure oh you're welcome Thanks
you